honey hey doing I'm here my boy Corey
Davis Nosgoth hey legacy of kain video
game yeah everyone loves them even if
it's outside of the genre I know you
guys got a little bit of because people
are like this new Legacy King come over
there oh man they saw that it wasn't a
straight up yes the remake of Soul
Reaver and I would love that but went
crazy but for the folks who are warm
familiar with it with a could you just
give us the sort of the basic edge on
one las got this or so nosgoth is a
competitive multiplayer asymmetrical
game set in the world of legacy of kain
so we've taken nosgoth without going to
Lourdes too much you know in Soul Reaver
if you played that razzy Oh gets cast
down into the abyss by Kane thousands of
years later the game happens we're in
that interim where the world isn't
decided yet as humans and vampires
battling it out and we're trying to fill
in the gaps a little bit without you
know stepping on the previous games or
anything like that sure fair enough yeah
how long have you guys been working on
this about two years and it's psionics I
know you've worked on stuff before sure
socionics is a independent studio in San
Diego okay and we've done a lot of yeah
yeah very close it's great great Mexican
food we love it great Mexican readers on
Athene's and carne asada hands yeah
carne asada n beans yeah so you know
we've done a lot of help and other games
so like we helped out on we do a lot of
Unreal Engine work so we helped out on
here's a war we helped out on mass
effect 3 multiplayer we did the
multiplayer on Bulletstorm okay lots a
little like you know helping out here
and there behind the scenes and this is
our first sort of big public release
with square enix excellence so I believe
we've got some mad gameplay and we've
got some live footage as well if we can
shoot to some of that stuff be great I
think it's one of those games you kind
of need to definitely too good to get a
hold on it so I mean the big thing with
Nosgoth is it's asymmetrical so the
humans have weapons range weapons and
the vampires are entirely melee and so
it's all about how that interplay you
know can you stop these super-strong
vampires before they get to you as a
vampire can you close that gap and kill
this guy that's shooting at you with a
weapon cool so we're looking at gameplay
here yeah you just kind of give us a
skivvy on the moment to my door so we're
seeing a human perspective here this is
our new map that we're showing at e3 the
phain it's the first vampire map
fans of the series will notice they're
fighting near Raziel statute right now
there's a lot of throwbacks to the
series that we try to put in there this
is the prophet our newest human class
she's sort of like a dual wielding blood
which she's pretty nasty we're all about
our humans aren't the good guys you know
they're both really we look at them as
they're both bad hmm the humans are bad
the vampires are bad they're fighting
over this land and I mean the key here
is we really have an emphasis on team
play yeah humans need to stick together
defend each other use their abilities
each of our classes has a unique set of
abilities like you might see in a mobile
or an MMO and all that comes together as
a sort of you know work together defend
each other or you're going to die if you
get split up the vampires are all about
picking you off yet by one and so the
classes in this are they are they pre
setted you said it's 5 p-5 is that
correct it's for before before so
there's currently four classes but
there's no restrictions on who can play
what ok so you could have four of the
same could have for the same is a great
idea you try to balance it so that's not
the ideal strategies but we don't want
to put hard limits on anything you said
you've got suited for maps already I
know you guys are beta at the moment as
well alright this is the fifth map are
there certain maps that require you to
take a specific class strategy do you
feel there are certain maps that have
slight advantages but we don't want to
see gameplay where you're okay this maps
loading everyone play the flying vampire
right yeah so we definitely try to play
up those advantages in different ways
but we don't want to have that landslide
of a change in a certain map Wow could
you tell us a little bit then them at
the different classes because we're sort
of getting it who's who at the moment
we're spirals so this is the Sentinel
it's one of our most interesting classes
he can actually fly indefinitely so okay
as a human you hear wings flapping above
you get scared we've you know we pushed
the verticality a lot our vampires can
climb every wall in every map wow so
you're constantly on your toes is it you
know you can't just watch in front and
behind you have to watch above and the
Sentinels the epitome of that he can
actually pick humans up carry them away
from their team and drop them to their
death so then you can counter it so if
you hear those wings comin in his Tim
screech you know it's time to roll or do
something evasive
this is some human gameplay again this
is our Alchemist he's using a
flamethrower ability so one that's a
sweet piece of Alcatraz pretty early
thrower so she's a good example of what
we try to do with our class design she's
not just a DPS character you can edit
your loadout for different abilities she
can actually play as a healer if she
wants to but she can't have the
flamethrower at the same time right is
that true for all the classes yes a lot
of differentiation yeah every class we
try to allow multiple roles and play
styles within the class they're all side
grades not upgrades you know we are free
to play but we're not pay-to-win so
everything gameplay relevant is not an
advantage over whatever you start with
and you can earn everything just by
playing sweet I've got a bunch of
questions coming in already your vm in
the town is wondering at what platforms
is coming out on so we're on steam on pc
right now we don't have anything
announced yet for any consoles that said
we just added controller support so you
can play with an xbox or playstation
controller so we think it's a natural
fit for a console do you think
eventually this is a sort of thing where
you'd like to see if I get on some sort
of concept we think yeah next-gen would
be a really great target excellent I'm
all right I'm gonna keep getting a
couple more questions here at your beta
is closed right it is closed right now
you can get beta keys i believe from you
guys and in general and twitter we don't
have a date on open beta but we feel
like we're pretty close we're currently
revamping matchmaking in parties we want
that to be rock solid before we go out
to open beta have you thought about
early access at all head is that
conversation so we're on early access
right now you are currently yeah so
there's a couple options to get in right
now if you just cannot wait and can't
find a beta key but you know it's been
invaluable for us whereas sonics were a
big community driven studio so we're
always on the forums playing the game
with people watching twitch streams so
you know we take people's feedback into
account the way we look at it is you
know we released a new class players are
going to do stuff with that character
that we didn't think of within the show
five minutes of it being out and so
we're all about community feedback at
balancing I'm interested in what the
sort of crossover between the legacy of
kain there are fans and this is because
this is a first of all it's a pc game
yeah i can see if Cain yeah I believe
Soul Reaper had a pc long release mostly
plants thought it was predominantly a
sort of appreciation game do you find us
a lot of your community our folks who
are ya invested in the lower or they
invest in this type of gameplay more
we've seen a pretty even split so
there's you know half of our players
just want to kill people they don't want
to wait for a story cutscene to happen
just to get in the game and start
murdering people the other half it's
been really gratifying to see these
hardcore single-player legacy of kain
fans say you know I've never been a
multiplayer gamer but this made me give
it a chance and it's a lot of fun yeah
that must be it stays really cool
especially after I guess I'm not sure
how I remember at the time der being a
sort of a a and then i wouldn't say
negative reception but perhaps an
apathetic one arrangement that like and
there might have been a new Legacy cane
game by and it ended up not being what a
lot of people wanted yeah and for you
guys what was that like were you did you
sort of go after the legacy of kain for
IP or was this something that was given
to you as part of a publishing danger we
were approached I mean this is square
enix's IP right they're all about legacy
of kain we would love to see a new
single-player l ok just as much as
anyone else but ultimately we're a
multiplayer studio we're all about
making the best multiplayer game we can
so you know when we saw that there were
two things that happened one was we said
well we need to get this game out get
gameplay footage out let people see what
the game is about because that's what
we're showing the other was we actually
took some of the feedback to heart
immediately we worked with daniel camuto
he was a concept artist on Soul Reaver
Oh fantastic and you know some players
said I love the game but the vampires
don't look just like the vampires did in
Soul Reaver ok and what we basically did
was work with him made some new skins
for the vampires that make you look much
more like those clans did in Soul Reaver
ok we're calling them evolve skins and
you can earn them just by playing so our
other skins are premium you know that's
how we monetize the game these you can
actually earn just by leveling up those
characters excellent so anybody that
wants to be the authentic razzy alone
here on the old games yeah excellence as
so in terms of that leveling system is
that on a car
character basis or is that an individual
account we have both so there's an
overall progress bar that lets you
unlock things automatically but each
class also has a level and that's gates
like prestige stuff like skin so
ultimately want to say you see a guy
that you see a hunter in this match he
had to skin you know that guys played a
lot of Hunter he's really good yeah i'm
seeing i wanted i want to keep your
distance Oh exactly exactly yeah so is
this is this using Unreal Engine this is
the Unreal Engine 3 excellence cap we're
a big Unreal Engine studio like it yeah
bulletstorm yeah the facts I'm hearing a
bunch they've got a great relationship
with that big we're big fans yeah for
sure put a storm won't spare by the way
it's pretty great thank you yeah is
there ever gonna be a bullet storm two I
don't know I bet you gotta talk to epic
about right I don't know who to talk to
epic at anymore they all seem to be off
doing that alone I would like to know
what they're doing to actually yeah for
sure I although i buy ya a couple of
weeks ago on a show i said that epic
were probably done making games when
time said that they were doing on a
tournament or so I can't you know yeah
what can I say goes so what's the future
plans for you guys you're in clothes
made at the moment you brought your for
map set there seems like your classes
are set in stone so we're adding more
classes okay so some of the footage we
saw was our newest human that we just
rolled out the profit that was our
fourth so we're now four and four we
don't feel like we're done we definitely
like to get to five or six per side at
least but probably not for open beta you
know that's more long term plans but
like I said earlier you know we want to
add more depth of each class too so I
don't see this game ever being like
every week there's a new hero right it's
more like we get to a comfortable number
and then we look at how we can add depth
to existing characters and then I guess
the the 4v four is not the only mode you
guys have or their variance alone in the
beta right now there's four before team
deathmatch that's the stock mode and
there's a domination inspired mode
called seeds where the humans are
capturing objectives and vampires are
doing everything they can to prevent
that okay we're looking at more modes
going forward that's one of the top
priorities is you know we feel like we
nailed the basics and now this next step
is what's a game mode that I can't get
anywhere else is it a vampire and I have
to murder a guy and drag his body across
the level to capture you know stuff like
that cool and I assume you're probably
talking to your community about a lot of
that's all the time
how has that been in terms of getting
the feedback like you get feedback on
maps as well like very much so it's
mostly character classes which is
standard for these sepa games you only
just put out the profit within about two
hours there was a prophet is opie thread
so I mean but we take that all with a
grain of salt but no it's good i mean
people are especially i think because
it's a beta and if you get into not
Scott you seem to be very committed type
of person we get really constructive
useful feedback and the fans have been
great excellent so what's the next send
a couple of months look like for you
guys in terms of race when are you
opening it up to more people and when
would it be eventually released on PC so
we don't have a release date we feel
like we're getting close to an open beta
we're just not setting a date we're
saying when it's ready okay because we
don't want to miss anything the real
focus now is finishing this map out so
it's not available yet we're showing it
any three but we got to put some more
finishing touches on it and then it's
just working on more content and like I
said making sure matchmaking parties all
that stuff is rock-solid awesome Corey
Davis I'm soundex thanks so much for
bringing nothing to show for Anna yeah
best of luck with your launch later this
year hopefully later this year hope to
see you again at 2014 and we've got one
more at game while I've got one more
game left here open the Samsung stage
I'm very excited about code names team
which was announced by nintendo it's
coming to 3ds I'm gonna get some
sick-ass b-roll that a Philly has never
been shown before but right now we're
gonna check out what's going on the show
floor